Riverdale delivers a sexy, updated take on
the classic Archie comics, but what would
it look like if the cast was a little closer
to their comics counterparts?
Jughead Jones
To take on an angsty version of Jughead, Cole
Sprouse dyed his naturally blonde hair to
dark brown, and he sports the character’s
signature hat, no matter how weird it might
be.
The only thing that keeps him from being a
dead ringer is Jughead’s Pinocchio-style
nose.
Archie Andrews
Like Kevin Keller said in episode one: Archie
got hot.
K.J.
Apa's Archie is super-jacked, with red-dyed
hair alongside thick black eyebrows of the
comics.
He makes viewers believe that Archie Andrews
could be the kind of guy two best friends
would fight over for eighty years.
But he's still missing the trademark freckles
and clumsiness of the comics.
Betty Cooper
Riverdale’s resident brilliant blonde is
played by Lili Reinhart, who sports Betty’s
iconic ponytail… when she’s not sporting
a wig as “Dark Betty.”
Reinhart’s hair is a little darker than
the cartoon blonde of the comics, and she
lacks the bangs that Betty is usually depicted
with.
Other than that, though, she could’ve stepped
off the page.
Veronica Lodge
Brazilian-American actress Camila Mendes said
she wasn’t planning on auditioning for Veronica
until she found out the producers were making
the character Latina, and that she like liked
that the character “wasn’t a stereotype.”
Aside from the change in background and the
Bettie Page bangs that Veronica has in the
comics, Mendes is virtually identical to Riverdale’s
richest teenager.
Cheryl Blossom
Cheryl Blossom was once banned from Archie
comics for being too sexy, but Madelaine Petsch
steals the show as the River Vixens’ dramatic
HBIC, whether she’s involved in a murder
mystery or shooting enemies with arrows.
Like Cheryl of the comics, Petsch is redheaded,
although her hair's darker than in the comics,
and her brown eyes depart from Cheryl’s
green.
Kevin Keller
Kevin Keller made headlines in 2010 when he
was introduced as the first openly gay character
in Archie Comics, and has been a mainstay
of the cast ever since.
Actor Casey Cott's hair is dark brown, along
with green eyes.
Those are both departures from comic book
Kevin Keller, who sports wavy blonde hair,
and bright blue eyes.
Ms. Grundy
The character we think is Geraldine Grundy
isn't.
Jennifer Gibson stole Grundy’s identity
and started an inappropriate relationship
with 15 year-old Archie.
34 year-old Sarah Habel is pretty different
from comics-Grundy in every way.
We eventually see the “real” Ms. Grundy
in the newspaper, looking exactly like her
comics counterpart, but otherwise, we’re
far from the source here.
Fred Andrews
On TV, former teen heartthrob Luke Perry sports
a full head of hair and chiseled good looks,
showing exactly where his son Archie gets
his handsomeness.
That's a stark contrast to comic book Fred
Andrews, who's overweight and nearly bald.
And it's a good thing, too: a bald, mustachioed
Luke Perry is not the Luke Perry we want.
Hiram Lodge
As Hiram Lodge, Mark Consuelos has a sinister
cool, the physique to grapple on the wrestling
mat, and the edge to intimidate mobsters like
Poppa Poutine.
But “cool” and “sinister” aren’t
words that could plausibly describe him in
the comics.
With white hair, a thick mustache, and glasses,
Hiram's a stuffy businessman who tends to
fall into swimming pools.
Toni Topaz
Toni Topaz was introduced into the comics
as a potential love interest for Jughead,
which meant she was a competitive eater who
crushed the competition at a cupcake-eating
contest.
On the show, Vanessa Morgan's ability to scarf
down desserts has yet to be fully explored,
but beyond that, she bears a pretty strong
resemblance to her comics counterpart.
Penny Peabody
Penny Peabody is definitely the most obscure
character to make it to the screen, originally
appearing as a child in the Little Archie
spinoff.
Brit Morgan brings her to TV as a ruthless
attorney working for the Southside Serpents,
and given what happens between her and Jughead,
it’s probably for the best that Riverdale
made her a much older woman.
Nick St. Clair
Unlike most characters on Riverdale, Nick
St. Clair wasn't originally designed for the
cartoony style that we all recognize from
Archie Comics.
Instead, he was introduced as a modern "bad
boy."
Graham Phillips lacks the spiky hair and soul
patch from the comics, but otherwise, he absolutely
plays Nick with the same smug smarminess that
makes him so hateable.
The Red Circle
In the comics, "Red Circle" a line of superhero
comics featuring characters like the Shield,
Jaguar, and Fly Girl.
Riverdale transformed that idea by having
Archie get inspired to form a vigilante gang
of masked, shirtless teens after reading too
many funnybooks.
The only thing that would’ve made it weirder
is if Archie actually started fighting crime
as the Shield.